talk about the time in your life you
decide to go in on that audition for
Francis Ford Copo and standing in the
room there the other guys that audition
for that movie Tom Cruz alilio Estes
Dennis Quaid Scott beo and and Tommy
Howell that's a pretty [__] crazy
group right Micky roor I mean any actor
from 35 to 15 was there was there not
only there but there while you
auditioned what do you mean you mean
they wait in the waiting room no they're
they're watching
we're in a big sound Francis had just
bought a studio z z Trope right and he
had us sit in chairs lying like a big
circle now is that unusual unheard of
why did he do that cuz Francis does
whatever he wants to do and and were you
nervous being in that group oh are you
kidding I mean I I'm saying every single
actor you could Timothy Hutton who had
just did ordinary PE everybody and if a
guy [__] up and does a bad audition and
that
that's and and and would they laugh at
you would they ridicule a guy if he was
bad no be deadly silent just be like and
and and and then Francis would would
literally point to somebody and say you
up you sit so like have you reading with
each other and then changing your and
they say okay great now read this other
part which you hadn't prepared for oh my
God and and you and you got the movie I
did that had to be a big boost to you
right it was I mean I didn't know which
was more exciting that I had survived
that competition or that I was actually
going to be in this movie did anybody
screw up that day that you remember yeah
who screwed up well I I the screen tests
are out there on YouTube they're kind of
out there and they're really really
interesting and I'll never forget Tom
Cruz in the auditioning for my role for
soda pop and in the middle of the big
speech just going you know what I'm so
sorry I just need to stop this just
isn't working for me and I thought isn't
working for you you don't do that I was
like wow wow that's unbelievable but
that's that's speaks to who Tom is manuz
he's gnarly he's he's a killer in a
great way is so is that why he's such a
success because he has such a great
sense of who he is he has a great sense
of who he's just driven and doesn't
suffer uh those kind of insecure foibles
and um you're good friends with him
still right yeah I think he's the I I
don't see him as much as I'd like but I
I think he's amazing and he was all
those guys on on that movie they're like
the guys who I in my fraternity at
college right you know I can go my whole
life I ran into Ralph machio I was doing
the East Street radio right uh and and
Ralphie came in and we because we were
the two kid we were the Springsteen
nerds on the movie so it's it's I
anytime I see any of the guys I'm just
ecstatic Diane Lane was in that movie oh
my gosh now that is one of the great
beauties of our time right all time
still is were you in love with her
instantly when you saw her she wouldn't
give any of us the time of day is that
true oh Matt Dylan tried to close it I
think he he did like four movies after
that just to try to close it I think the
scripts were shitty but he was like Dian
in it great this is going to be the
movie where it's going to
happen